[Music]
like it or not it's this game now
i've always loved a little puzzle
what are we looking for
more symbols
jesus's next victim is bruce wayne it
can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
the answer's justice
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler is asking for you the killer
left this for the batman why is he lying
to you
are you okay
i've been trying to reach you
there's latest it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
in life to be over
we all have our scars bruce you're still
a wine
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know she's a delaney
where are you there
what are you hiding
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence
you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
you